let's turn to nancy court as she's at
the white house with more on the story
nancy good morning to you what is the
biden administration doing about this
well they're now fielding questions from
consumer advocates gail about the fda's
inspection process people wondering
whether this harmful bacteria that was
found in the plant in michigan that
adriana mentioned could have been
detected sooner
in the meantime officials here at the
white house say they're going to cut
some packaging regulations to help get
new products on the shelves faster
they're also calling for crackdowns on
price gouging which as you can imagine
could become a big problem and they're
working on importing more formula from
overseas yesterday president biden spoke
with some of the ceos of major retailers
and manufacturers about how to increase
production and inventory and the white
house isn't ruling out the possibility
that the president might invoke the
defense production act to quickly ramp
up supply but here's the bottom line
tony they say as of right now they
really can't predict
when parents will see more supply on
store shelves
and that is the truly scary part nancy
thank you very much